I come from a culture of storytellers.
Our oldest legends stretch back
to a time of the supernatural.
They're so ancient, they begin long ago,
before time began,
when the world was both light and dark.
So I thought we could discuss the story
of story itself, of legacy.
In a Western sense,
legacy is the mark
a person leaves on history.
Statues are raised for the heroes,
for those that are revered.
In my culture,
we see it a bit differently.
(Speaking Haida)
I am Taaydal.
It's closest, direct translation
is "coming in big."
(Laughter)
I come from Haida Gwaii,
an archipelago off the northwest
coast of British Columbia,
where, on a clear day,
you could paint the shores
of the Alaskan panhandle
from our northern beaches.
Our legacy or the stories told about us,
at least internationally,
is of our monumental Haida art,
our intricate 40-foot story poles,
our longhouses and canoes
and our dance masks,
which are all internationally
renowned and collected.
It is, however, our weaving that,
in my opinion, is the unsung hero.
I dare say our entire culture and society
was supported by our weaving,
be it the clothing we wore
or the rope for our fishermen
or the baskets we wove to collect
and store our food for winter.
When you weave a cedar basket,
you have your warps,
which cascade down your form,
and you have your weft,
which spirals continuously around it,
incorporating itself over and under
your warps to create your basket.
We are, I think, the weft,
trying to find our way around the form,
being careful not to miss a step
or make a mistake,
or for some of us,
trying not to unravel altogether.
That's how I think of legacy,
as the weaving together of our stories
passed on as a whole.
And it may seem a little esoteric,
but I'd love to give you an example.
250 years ago,
approximately 20,000 Haidas
thrived on the shores of Haida Gwaii.
Less than 600 remained
at the end of the 19th century.
So it was 250 years ago
that an explorer arrived,
sailing on the ship, "Santiago,"
the first European to do so.
So what was his legacy?
Was it the inlet that's named
after him on Haida Gwaii?
Or what I assume
were the unintended consequences
of smallpox and tuberculosis,
our potlatch bans, residential schools,
the burning of our masks
and poles as firewood,
or the collectors who came
and ransacked the villages
that we were forced to abandon?
That is the colonial legacy.
Our legacy is of those 600 Haidas
who stood against the well-oiled machinery
of an empire that sought to destroy them.
And though they have no inlets
that bear their names,
their legacy can be seen
every time we stand up
and say, “We are the Haida nation.”
Their legacy was on display last fall
when my clan, the K’ayaahl Laanas,
the sea lion town people,
descended from those born
at K’ay Llnagaay, Ts’aahl Llnagaay,
Xaayna, Kaysuun and Niisii,
held a potlatch.
A potlatch is when clans
and nations come together
for the purposes of feasting
and conducting business
like a chief being inaugurated,
or a person receiving a name
or a death or a marriage.
We witness these business
transactions to support
or even to defend them if necessary.
Our potlatch was memorial pole raising,
honoring our late Chief Gaahlaay.
A memorial pole is, in and of itself,
a symbol of wealth and status,
much like a statue.
Where they differ is in the rings
that are carved up the pole,
each one representing a potlatch,
the real measure of wealth for a chief,
marking each occasion that a chief
and his clan came together
and they redistributed their wealth
beyond their needs
to ensure that other clans and nations
could survive the winter as well.
My piece of the story began
on a beautiful fall afternoon.
The type of day you would
take a jacket with you
and only ever end up
carrying it around everywhere you go.
I had no sooner landed in Haida Gwaii
than I was in a speedboat,
skimming across the inlet
to our traditional village site
of Xaayna Llnagaay, or Sunshine Town.
And as I leapt off the bow onto the shore,
I was told that we just missed
the Royal Canadian Mounted Police,
or Mounties,
who had come over on their speedboat
to sleuth out the cause of the smoke
that was billowing into the sky.
They wanted to make sure
that Maude Island wasn't on fire.
You see, there was a bonfire
going on the beach,
and we were burning
the branches from trees
that we had been removing
to unveil big rectangles of sunken earth
where our longhouses once stood.
And for me, the smoke
was a bat signal in the sky.
The K’ayaahl Laanas have returned home.
Shortly after arriving,
I was six feet deep in the Earth
and working to reach seven.
I'd arrived late to the digging party,
but it was my honor to complete
the final foot necessary
so that the pole we would be raising
in a few days' time
was seated deep enough in the Earth
that the greatest winds
of Haida Gwaii wouldn't topple it.
What made the moment even more powerful
were the treasures we found
during the initial digging:
a portion of a carved stone bowl,
blue and red glass trade beads
that came by way of Russian traders
all the way from Bohemia.
In a way, we were reawakening the spirits
that were held in the land
where external forces once drove us
to abandon those shores,
now we were coming home,
and they were there waiting for us.
Hundreds of fellow community members,
clans and relatives
from our other nations
came together to help us raise the pole.
It began with an offering
of food burned in the fire,
a gift to our ancestors.
The drum sounded,
announcing a canoe coming ashore,
carrying the carvers of the pole,
the current Chief Gaahlaay
and the daughter
of our late chief, Gwaaganad.
The wild man of the woods
was drummed through the village
to clear out any unwelcome spirits.
And the pole, which at the time
lay on the forest floor,
was cleansed with cedar boughs
dipped in ocean water
and brushed along its length.
And new offerings of glass beads
were placed into the hole.
So that centuries from now,
long after this pole has decayed
and returned to the Earth,
they would find those treasures from us
when the next pole
was raised in its place.
Thick ropes that were tied
around the midsection of the pole
were stretched down the beach
to the water's edge,
and all those who were able
found a place along it.
And from that first instruction to pull,
it took only moments
for the pole to rise up
and become a permanent beacon
for the next 200 years,
that this place is Xaayna Llnagaay
and it remains the village
of the K’ayaahl Laanas Xaaydagaay.
Over this two-day event of feasting
and raising the pole,
I stood in the role of master of ceremony
alongside my clan brother, Gaagwiis.
It's a role I inherited from
and share with my maternal uncle
Kilslaay Kaadjii Sdin.
And during our potlatch,
we shared in our songs and our stories,
in our language and in our art,
in our traditions and in our deep
relationship with our lands and waters.
That is true legacy.
That is the warps that make up my basket.
And I am the weft that weaves myself
through them to become a basket,
that everything else
I learn and do in my life
can be collected in to pass on.
That day I received this copper shield
alongside of the name Taaydal.
Perhaps you've had
the same name since birth
and will continue to have
the same name until you die.
Well, in my culture,
we are often the caretakers
of multiple names over our lifetime.
Last year, I would have first
introduced myself as Gidin Kuns.
Now I am Taaydal,
but I do continue
to hold the name Gidin Kuns
until such a time as my sister has a child
and I can pass the name on to them.
It is our duty to build on the wealth
and status of our names,
not just ourselves.
This shield is a witness to the creation
of that wealth and status.
It is present at significant occasions:
as I received my name,
it was there at my wedding,
and tonight it is here,
witnessing me speaking to all of you.
Each of these occasions
becomes tied to it,
and one day when I pass
on the name of Taaydal,
I will recount all
that the shield has witnessed
and ensure that those stories
are carried on with it.
It's a concept I encourage each of you
to borrow in your own unique way.
The decisions we make today
will make the difference
on whether or not our descendants
will have all the warps in place
to weave their own basket,
to collect new knowledge and stories in.
We must not allow our environment
to continue to worsen
to a point where none of us
can carry on our cultures.
We must be willing
to do our business in the light.
Make decisions in which we can proudly
celebrate with our families
and our communities
or even our constituents.
Mark individual achievement,
but celebrate our collective well-being.
And build up our names
so we are proud to pass them on.
Personal legacy is inevitable,
as unavoidable as the passage of time.
And while you may want
to prioritize your personal legacy
to be the one with statues
erected in your honor
or an inlet that bears your name,
I ask you to consider
the collective legacy
of those unnamed 600.
They're the only reason
that I'm standing here today.
Will future generations
look back at us in gratitude
for all of the gifts we have left them?
I would hate for them to look back at me
and all they could say is,
"Wow, he must have been pretty impressive.
He even got a statue."
Háw'aa, merci, thank you.
(Applause)